on this episode we talk to da ki about
how large healthcare companies can start
to gain the benefits of running in the
cloud so how is the cloud kind of been a
catalyst to making this change in the
industry is hope yeah it's a great
question so if you look at traditionally
most big healthcare related companies
are not really on the cloud they are
usually on their own data centers moving
to cloud has many challenges so one is
regulatory and compliance challenge we
are seeing that most cloud providers
today are HIPAA compliant out-of-the-box
which reduces the sort of barrier of
entry but it's still pretty hard for
them to new massive amounts of data to
cloud because there is cost associated
with it but the stickiness aspect with
the cloud is that you don't have to
build tools from ground up because there
are so many services out of the box that
the cloud offers that it makes valuable
because it's a question of opportunity
cost can you get to market sooner
however still there are like enough
challenges for big healthcare players to
be on the cloud what we are seeing at
doc here in startups which is a start-up
basically we don't have that issue we
can be unplowed we are cloud native from
get-go so we want it to be scalable
resilient and use all the services out
of the box so that we can get to market
sooner what we have seen as we were able
to get to market significantly faster
not having to worry about infrastructure
or managing servers and used plethora of
services that Google cloud provides a
great example of that is kubernetes
engine and along with all the other
containers that we can easily roll out
and other tied up services like SQL
proxy and so on which makes it really
easy for us to like not have a big
infrastructure and DevOps team but focus
on ruling out product features so it's
been great that way to be on at all and
that makes sense for startups who you
know they want to be cloud native they
need to get to market sooner it's really
easy to be agile when you learn small
what would you say the most important
kind of cloud technologies or cloud
related resources are available to
larger companies that can help them
adopt
similar methodology that's a great
question so so I think it's a
multi-phase approach for bigger
companies that are not on cloud already
so what I suggest is that any of the new
products and services that you want to
roll out you want to consider being on
the cloud first so some principles of
being cloud native means that you can
use some of the open source technology
so that you're not necessarily locked
into one cloud vendor and you have the
option allottee of being able to run
that back on your data center so the
first suggestion from my point of view
is that you start building new services
and products as sort of a cloud native
version that can run on any cloud
including your own data center second
phase of that would be how do you sort
of bring other interesting data that you
sit on in your own data centers and use
that in conjunction with the data that's
being collected on your new services and
products so you could bring your own
data to the cloud or you could sync the
data back from the clock to your own
data centers where you are now building
much more robust set of models or
services but over time as phase 3 I
would say that you may want to consider
moving a lot of your computational needs
onto the cloud the challenge with that
is at scale cloud becomes pretty
expensive an example of that would be if
you are building a lot of interesting
models that require a lot of CPU
computational resources then these are
pretty expensive on a per hour basis so
it's still very valuable to consider
moving to a cloud but then build it and
design it in a way that you are not tied
to a specific cloud and there are many
open-source tools and technologies that
let you do that so that way you can
bring it back up and it isn't a bad joke
yeah and a hybrid approach is still
that's you know not only relatable but
actually really desirable to a lot of
people so how does that relate to the
cloud before right and so it depends on
where you are in the company's journey
so a big established company may have
already own the real estate for having
the their own data centers so the
marginal cost of adding the server would
still look far more lucrative
them to move to cloud as opposed to move
to cloud but what I see is that there is
going to be an explosion of different
tools and services and especially new
type of computation environments that
you can get for example you're seeing
people use that Google is is pioneering
and rolling out it'll almost be
impossible to bring those two back to
your data centers so in some way you're
right that it's better to be on cloud
because you can manage costs certainly
in some way because you only use it on
on-demand but then with already at scale
certain companies find it easier and
cheaper to roll out new machines but not
necessarily offering the same
capabilities it's an opportunity cost of
the future versus marginal cost or the
present day that these big companies
have to make a trade-off
the initial cost will be higher on the
cloud simply because to replicate the
same level of computational resources
it's going to be expensive but with the
right sort of themes and right
infrastructure teams in place where you
are not spinning up resources and
wasting your way you can somehow have a
handle on the cloud but I think really
it's the future of where your products
can go which i think is only possible
being the provider stay tuned for more
conversations with da ki if you enjoyed
this episode
check out the stack tap playlist for
more great videos
[Music]
you